DAVID FEUER: Hello all, and
welcome to API 302, GraphQL:
Building a Consistent
Approach for the API Consumer.
My name is David Feuer,
the head of global platform
strategy at Apigee, a part
of Google Cloud platform.
And I'm joined today
by Miguel Mendoza,
a lead architect at Apigee, a
part of Google Cloud Platform.
Today we're going
to go over what
is GraphQL, what it's
good for, and what
are some of the
expected features that
are missing from GraphQL.
Secondly, we're going
to go over consistency.
What's the point of
consistency, and walk
through REST best
practices, and then
translating that to GraphQL.
Lastly Miguel
Mendoza's going to do
a demo for us, of how
we would implement
some of this on top of Apigee.
The first thing I'd like to
say is that GraphQL is awesome.
GraphQL has some
terrific benefits.
And if I had to break down
some of these benefits,
I would break them down
to three key areas.
The fact that there's a single
endpoint, so all the data
is exchanged [INAUDIBLE]
a single endpoint.
So granularity for data
load and execution requests
in parallel, query
planning, all of that
is super straightforward
in GraphQL.
The second is an incredibly
powerful query language
that prevents over fetching
and under fetching of data,
as opposed to,
let's say, in REST,
where many of the requests
have to be sequential.
And then lastly, GraphQL
client libraries.
So GraphQL is no
longer only the domain
of the ReactJS UI framework.
But it's also available
for other client libraries
and for other languages
and paradigms.
So that GraphQL is truly useful
to most developers today.
So why isn't GraphQL everywhere?
I think ultimately, this
comes down to a bifurcation
that we're seeing in the market.
The first is that developer
programs are frequently
separated from API programs.
Developer programs
tend to be external
facing or internal facing
between business units,
so that the author of the
server and client are different.
In APIs, frequently
what we see is
that the author of
the client and server
are a tight-knit group of
people, or the same person.
And that's why we're
seeing more of GraphQL.
I think part of that has
to do with consistency.
We'll talk about that today.
But fundamentally,
self-service developer programs
are a growth strategy.
And so developer
programs are a way
of getting internal partner and
external developers leveraging
your APIs, as opposed to API
programs, which are typically
an infrastructure strategy
driving interoperability
and decomposition of your
internal infrastructure.
So what are the benefits of
GraphQL, why use GraphQL?
Well, we talked a little bit
about some of the differences.
Let's do a little
bit of a deep dive.
REST has multiple different
endpoints, and the URL taxonomy
that's used as a
logical resource manager
for different types of APIs.
In GraphQL, there's
really one endpoint.
And longer and larger
queries for customer data
encapsulate all the different
value and different value
propositions that
you would normally
see in those different
URLs in REST.
In interactions,
REST uses HTTP VERBs,
and generally uses JSON XML in
order to exchange that data.
In GraphQL, GraphQL uses
POST most of the time,
And also leverages
different query types
specified inside the
protocol, not in HTTP,
so there's no VERBs there, just
a custom query language called
Schema Definition Language.
So even though it's a custom
query language on the request,
JSON is returned, which makes
it much easier for clients.
But there's a
significant difference
in the interaction mechanism.
Documentation is
different, whether it's
OpenAPI specs and
portals on the REST side,
really in GraphQL, there's a
schema generated documentation.
Frequently, it
will see customers
using Graphical, or
GraphQL Playground,
in order to interact with
schema based GraphQL endpoints.
And then of course from
a discovery perspective,
the portal is the
Playground in REST
where a customer
would normally go,
or a developer would normally
go, to discover and interact
with REST APIs in order to
understand how they work.
In GraphQL, the
portal actually is
a built in Playground that
accommodates development.
It's almost like a
built in IDE, and so it
allows you to explore
new queries on the fly,
and use things
like tab completion
in order to discover those
queries in order to learn
how to use them better.
And so, we're not
here to talk about
whether you should
use GraphQL or REST,
our philosophy is that you
should use GraphQL and REST.
And I think one of
the best ways to do
that is to take some of
our REST-based practices
and apply them to GraphQL.
This is something that
we've seen in the market.
This is something that we
really see working really
well at a number of customers.
So we wanted to
bring those to you,
so that you could leverage them
and understand what those are.
The basis of this philosophy is
that APIs are digital products.
APIs are a way for an
enterprise to take its assets
and put it in the
hands of developers,
whether those developers are
internal employees, partners,
or external customers, in
order to grow the company's
leverage of those assets.
Because APIs are
digital products,
we rely on developers having a
consistent experience in order
to understand how to use
those digital products,
and build the compelling
experiences they need in order
to bring your assets to market.
And so consistency is
incredibly important
because developer friction
is a huge challenge
in adoption of APIs,
and in growth strategies
of digital companies.
Consistency in
GraphQL really starts
with a well-formed GraphQL.
And I think we can
learn a lot about that
from well-formed REST.
You would never expect
a well-formed REST query
to be list employees
by department.
That sounds like
a Java function.
A well-formed REST query
would be a resource.
Get employees, and
you pass employees ID.
And so that is what we
consider well-formed REST.
Nouns, And those
nouns are plural.
Graph hierarchy is fundamentally
a data-driven hierarchy, right?
So why do we frequently treat
it like a functional hierarchy?
Well-formed GraphQL shouldn't
look like the Java functions,
which it frequently does.
Well-formed GraphQL should
look like well-formed REST.
Why not use books, and
titles, and authors,
and treat this graphical
hierarchy the way
it should be treated, as
opposed to treating it
as a functional hierarchy.
And so the first
recommendation we have
is that you should
be data-oriented.
A graph hierarchy
is fundamentally
a data-driven hierarchy.
Be data-driven.
Treat it that way.
Don't be so function oriented.
The second recommendation
has to do with submitting
and retrieving data.
Those are not always
mirror operations.
We frequently see in REST,
leverage of CQRS, right?
We see retrieving data
from multiple services,
and a microservice
architecture, being
completely separate from
how to submit that data.
And so, as we think about
how to do this in GraphQL,
we specifically
think that mutations,
the way a GraphQL
developer submits data,
can get very complex
very quickly, especially
when there's a lot
of different types,
and especially when
submitting very little data.
Don't be afraid of CQRS.
Many of you have heard of
CQRS, which is Command Query
Responsibility Segregation.
It's a design pattern
that was first
identified by Martin Fowler.
And fundamentally, it's
just a different model
to update information than the
model used to read information.
And so we're seeing
in GraphQL programs,
especially in large enterprises,
especially those enterprises
that already have
REST, is that you
get the advantage of using
a REST-based frontend
by retrieving the
data with GraphQL,
but leveraging your existing
REST APIs in order to submit
that data to your backend.
The third pattern I'd
like to talk about
is optimizing for re-usability.
In REST, we think a lot about
our URL taxonomy, pagination,
filtering, and
creating consistency,
because developers can then
predict what the behavior will
be of an API call.
A developer sees the
REST API and goes, a-ha,
I know how to
interact with this.
Well, GraphQL, we should
be doing the same thing.
The challenge in large
enterprise GraphQL deployments
is that when it comes to
schema stitching, frequently,
different business units,
different lines of business,
are developing different
aspects of the schema,
and then stitching
that together in order
to look like one comprehensive
representation, one
big graph to hand to
an external developer.
The behavior of the
JSON returned though,
is frequently different,
because there is no consistency.
It wasn't built
as an API product
as part of a developer program.
It was built as an
internal API, sort
of a functional way of
interacting between components.
So when we think about relay
cursor connections and input
hints, all the uniform
behavior that you
would expect in a
REST API should also
exist in the GraphQL API.
So in GraphQL, we should be
very careful about optimizing
for re-usability, and
avoiding situations
where the developer is
confused, or otherwise
doesn't understand
why the behavior is
different in one
part of the schema
than it is in another
part of the schema.
And that's particularly
a problem with mutations,
because if you submit data to
one part of the schema one way,
and it gets recorded one
way, you don't always
realize that when
you submitted it
in another part
of the schema, it
got recorded another other way.
So mutations are even a larger--
a larger surface
area of challenges
when it comes to optimizing
for re-usability and API
productization.
And so be particularly
afraid there.
Be particularly conscientious
of the way you develop
and design mutations in GraphQL.
Lastly, I want to talk
about field names,
because this is something that
Miguel and I have experienced
personally.
It is developer hostile
to provide different data
and behavior for field
names with the same name
in different parts
of the schema.
So if there is a name field
in one part of the schema that
accepts first,
middle, last, name,
and then there's a name field in
another part of the schema then
expects last name
dot first name, that
is developer hostile.
You are not treating your
developers the way they expect
to be reques- the way
they expect to be treated,
and your developers will--
you will frequently experience
developer abandonment,
because your developers
will struggle
to adopt your GraphQL API.
So avoid the GraphQL
antipatterns.
Treat the graph as a
data-driven hierarchy.
Don't force GraphQL.
Use REST where and
when it makes sense.
And lastly, optimized
for re-usability.
Think about API products.
Think about the
developer experience,
and treating the
developer as the customer
they are, because you want
your GraphQL API to be used,
and you want it
to get to market.
There are challenges
in GraphQL deployments,
and I'm going to go over
these challenges very quickly,
because I think we're all
somewhat familiar with them.
AuthZ, authorization
authentication
is a huge challenge.
As you know, the
GraphQL spec delegates
AuthZ to the
business logic layer,
which means that it's
typically not handled
by the GraphQL server.
Throttling is a challenge.
There's no standard, like we
see an API productization,
for creating different levels
and different tiers of service,
and different access to
different APIs developers.
The third is analytics.
There's no unified
view of analytics,
which means leveraging APIs
as products, raising APIs
to the level of
business analytics,
as opposed to just
operational metrics,
is not something
that's possible.
And lastly, versioning
ops, we don't
understand how versioning
works in GraphQL,
and how particularly to address
the need for clients using
different versions
of different schemas
in order to implement
their applications.
So now you know what to do.
How do you do it?
For that, I'd like to
introduce Miguel Apigee is
a highly extensible and
customizable platform
with great out of
the box features.
But there are ways to
do other things with it.
There's FHIR support
for healthcare,
there's OpenBanking Support for
financial services companies,
and much more,
including GraphQL.
With that, I'd like to
hand it over to Miguel.
Miguel, take it away.
MIGUEL MENDOZA: All
right, so first,
let's take a look at an
overview of the architecture
for this demo.
On the left side, we have
the Apigee developer portal,
and in this developer portal,
we have the GraphQL Playground
embedded within the
Apigee developer portal.
Next, we have the Apigee
API gateway, which
is fronting Apollo GraphQL.
The Apollo GraphQL server
is running in Cloud Run.
Within the Apollo
GraphQL server,
there are also a couple
of Apigee plugins
that send logging and
tracing data to GCP.
Throughout this demo,
we're going to dive
into each of these components,
left to right, one at a time.
Let's go ahead and get started.
First let's go and take a
look at the developer portal.
I already have navigated
to developer portal,
so let me go to that.
Here, in the
developer portal, this
is an Apigee Drupal
developer portal
that has the GraphQL
Playground embedded.
As you can see
here, the Playground
has already been loaded
with an endpoint.
This endpoint is
the Apigee endpoint
that frames the
Apollo GraphQL server.
We can take a quick
look at the docs tab,
and we'll see the
schema that has been
loaded into the Playground.
All right, let's
take a look at it.
So this schema
represents a company
that aggregates trail and
lift data for ski resorts.
You can see the top level, we
have a ski resort data type,
and within the ski
resort type, we
have differing information
and some of that information
needs trails and lift data.
Let me show you a quick
diagram that shows this schema.
You can see here, the resort
type, and then under that,
we have trails and lift data.
This is the reading,
or the query schema.
There's also a
mutation schema, but I
won't show that yet,
we'll go to that later.
So let's head back into
the developer portal.
Let's run a query that list all
the resorts that are available.
So we do a query, list all
resorts, and for each resort,
let's just pull the
name of the resort.
And we can run this
query, and you can
see that we have three resorts.
Kirkwood Sierra at
Tahoe, and Heavenly.
Now, if I keep trying to run
this query multiple times,
let's see what happens.
You see, we had an error.
So we have a rate limiter.
This is Apigee that has
detected that the client has
sent too many requests over
a certain period of time.
So within Apigee, it's
running a quota policy,
and that policy
rejected the call.
So, how do we get around this?
One way to get around this is
to actually get an API key,
and maybe make a call
using a specific API
key that has a higher
entitlement, in terms
of calls per minute.
So let's do that.
Notice I'm not even logged in.
Apigee rejected a call based
on the client IP address,
and the number of calls
originating from that address.
So let's go ahead and log in
so that we can create an app
and get an API key
I already have an account that I
created earlier. so let me just
looking with that account.
Now let's go ahead
and create an app.
I'm going to call
my app peter-app.
And for this app, I'm going
to select a GraphQL Bronze API
product.
This product has a
higher entitlement,
so that I will be
able to make calls
without being worried so much
about the number of calls
per minute.
Right, so my app
has been created.
Now I should be able to get
the API key from this app.
Let's grab the API key
and secret for this app,
So here, we have the new
app that was created,
and we'll grab the API
key, or the consumer
key and the consumer secret.
I'm going to open the GraphQL
Playground in a new tab.
That way, I can just copy
paste as values over there.
So let me copy the consumer key.
All right, so back here
in the GraphQL Playground,
let's use the consumer key
and the consumer secret.
So in Apigee, we have
modified a GraphQL Playground
slightly to make this experience
a little bit smoother.
So on the top
right here, you can
see client credentials button.
This is a widget that
we have added expressly
for this purpose.
So let's click on here, and
let's add the client ID.
Right, so we have client ID.
Next, let's grab the client
secret, or the consumer secret.
And let's go back in here and
paste the consumer secret.
And you can also see the scopes
are going to be requested.
Basically this is a
proper Auth Flutter
that we're going to be doing.
And we're going to be requesting
a token that has introspection
and reading--
reader scopes.
Let's get a token.
Right, great.
So we have a token.
So this token came
from Apigee itself.
And we can take a look
at the token itself.
And you can see there's some
details about the token.
And we have the reader scope.
So let's go ahead
and close this.
Now, we should be able to
run this query multiple times
with this token that we
just got using the API key.
Let's do that.
And you can see now that
we're not hitting this limit
that we were hitting earlier.
Cool.
We're not getting
that error anymore.
So you can see that
since we got the API key,
and we were able to get a
token with the proper scope,
that error is going away.
What if we want to do
something else now?
Let's say we want to add a
resort to the current data set.
Let's take a look at the
schema for the mutations.
So if we look at mutations,
we have a resource mutation.
And if we want to create
a resort in this case,
this follows more like almost
like REST crowd example.
Create, delete, update.
So intuitively, to
create a resort,
we will go here into the
create resort mutation.
And you can see that the
create resort mutation
takes a create resort input.
And this is the data that
we're going to be passing in
to create a new resort.
So let's go ahead and do this.
One more thing.
Notice that-- it's
documented here
that in order to run
the resort mutation,
you need a site admin scope.
You'll see how that comes
into play in a second.
So let's try to run a mutation
for creating a resort.
Create new resort.
And this is going to
be the resort mutation.
And under the resort mutation,
we're going to go on create.
And for create, we're
going to pass an input,
and this input we're going to
give the name of the resort,
let's say this is
going to be Northstar.
And the base elevation,
let's say, 6,300 feet.
And the summit
elevation, 8,500 feet.
After we create a
new resort, let's
pull up the ID of the
resort which was created
and the name of the resort.
All right, so should be good,
let's try to run this now.
Oh, we got an error.
So again, this is Apigee
returning the error.
This is not coming from
the backend GraphQL server.
Apigee is saying,
hey, you're not
authorized to create a resort.
You don't have access
to these fields,
so you cannot access
the resort's mutation
and the resort mutation create.
So these fields
are not authorized
with the current key, or the
current token that I have.
So how do we make this work?
Obviously the token
that we have right now,
let's take a look at
it again, this token,
it only has these two scopes,
introspection and radar scopes.
And in order to be able
to run this mutation,
according to the mutation, we
need this site admin scope.
So in order to get a token
that has the site admin scope,
we need to have access to an API
product that offers that scope.
Or that offers those scopes.
So let's take a look
back at the API products.
So if we go back into the
app that we created earlier,
this app subscribes to the
GraphQL Bronze product.
This GraphQL Bronze product does
not offer the site admin scope.
In order to get this
site admin scope,
I need access to
another product.
So I have already created
another app called shredder,
and this app has access
to GraphQL Platinum.
So the GraphQL Platinum
product gives us
a higher level of
access, in terms
of different part of the
schema that we can access.
And this product has
already been approved,
and it's enabled for this app.
So let's switch to use the key
and secret for this other app.
Right let's grab the consumer
key and bring it over here.
Next, let's get the secret.
And finally let's change
the scope to site admin.
So this scope will
give us access
to a different
part of the schema.
Now let's get a token.
And we have a new token.
Hopefully now with
this new token,
we should be able to make the
call to create a new resort.
Let's do that.
Great, and you can see
the call is successful.
And we can verify that it
was successful by listing
all the resorts again.
Let's do that.
Right so we get all
resorts, let's get
the names of all the resorts.
And you can see here,
Northstar has been created.
All right, so you have seen two
important key functionalities
that Apigee is adding on top of
the existing GraphQL backend.
First, you saw
throttling, and then, you
saw field-level authorization.
Now let's peer
behind the curtain
to see how that is
done within Apigee.
Let me bring up the architecture
diagram, just to remind you
where we are.
So we're looking so far
at the developer portal.
Next, we're going to look
at the Apigee API gateway
to see how those throttling
and field-level authorization
were actually happening.
All right, let's head
over to the Apigee UI.
Great.
So here, this is
a proxy that was
driving the entire experience
you're seen so far.
The first policies
that you can see here
are coarse level
authorization policies.
It's just saying,
hey, do you even
have a valid token that
allows you to call this API?
Then we have the
throttling policy,
or the quota
policy, that checks,
are you allowed to make
the number of calls
you've been making so far?
Finally, we have the
fine-grained authorization
policy that checks whether
or not the current token has
the correct level of
access for the fields
within the specific query,
or the specific mutation
that's being sent to
the GraphQL server.
Let's take a look
at the quota policy.
You can see this policy has
been configured with a default
value of five calls per minute.
This is, in fact, the
behavior you saw initially
when I was making those
first calls to get
the list of resorts.
, Later once I created an
app and subscribed my app
to the Bronze, or the
GraphQL Bronze API product,
I was able to make more calls.
And that's defined outside,
that's defined in the product
itself.
So if we look at the
GraphQL Bronze product,
you can see that
the GraphQL Bronze
product has defined a quota
of 30 requests per minute.
Next, let's look at how the
fine-grain authorization
was working.
Here, you can see in the
GraphQL Bronze product
that I have defined a set
of allowed Auth scopes.
These are introspection
and reader scope.
I also have the
other product, which
was the GraphQL Platinum, which
has an even bigger set of Auth
scopes.
In addition to introspection
and reader scope,
it's got resort admin, resort
manager, and site admin.
Remember, we used
site admin when
we went when we went to
create the new resort.
So this is great.
You can see how
you're able to manage
both the SLA, the throttling
level, and the fine grain
authorization to the
GraphQL endpoint,
all within Apigee using the
concept of API products.
Now you may be asking
yourself, how are these scopes
being translated to individual
fields in the GraphQL schema?
Let's take a look at that next.
All right, so how do
we go from a scope
to an actual set of
fields, or an entitlement?
To do that, we have
stored the configuration
of a mapping of scopes to
fields in Apigee itself.
Let's take a look at that.
This is in Apigee
KVM, key value map.
So this is starting here, and--
let me open it so you can see.
For each scope, I
have listed here
the entitlement or
the set of fields
that this code is
allowed to access.
And in the case
of earlier, where
we are using this
site admin scope,
and you can see the site admin
has access to mutation resorts,
and mutation resorts wildcard.
Which means that if you
had this site admin scope,
you're token is allowed to
access any of these types
within the GraphQL schema.
All right so let's
go back to the proxy
and put it all together.
The first policy that runs
is the authorization policy.
This is coarse
level authorization.
It just checks hey,
do you have a token?
And once you have that token,
it extracts basically the scopes
that you have associated
with that token.
It also verifies that
this token is allowed
to access the proxy itself.
It doesn't check
individual fields,
but it extracts the scopes.
Then you have the quota
policy that checks, hey,
you are you still within
your allowed limit?
And then you have the fine
grain authorization policy.
For this fine grain
authorization policy,
it basically takes
the scope that
was associated with the token
that came in, and converts
that scope to a set
of entitlements,
or a set of fields,
and it checks
that the set of entitlements,
or a set of fields
that are allowed for this token,
satisfy all the fields that
came in in this specific query
or the specific mutation.
And if that's the
case, then Apigee
will go ahead and
let the call through,
and go through the
GraphQL backend.
And if not, then Apigee
returns an error.
Next, let's take a
look at what happens
after Apigee send a call
over to the actual GraphQL
backend server.
Let me bring up the
architecture diagram again.
The call came in from the
developer portal, arrived
at the Apigee API gateway,
Apigee checked the call
for security, coarse level
and fine-grain field level
authorization.
It also did throttling checks,
and then it sent the call over
to the actual Apollo
GraphQL server.
This server, I have it
running in GCP, in Cloud Run.
And within here, I
have the Apollo server.
I have added a couple
of Apigee plugins
that allow you to send data
over to GCP cloud login,
and also to cloud tracing.
And this data is sent
asynchronously in batches.
So it does not affect the
runtime of the main call
itself.
Let's hop over to
the Google Cloud
console and take a look
at some of this data.
Here, I have the GCP
log viewer, and I'm
showing the create new resort
mutation that we ran earlier.
You can see the actual payload
for the mutation that's
being logged, as well as a
timestamp for this mutation.
Let's go over to the trace.
So here, each of these dots
represent an individual query
or mutation that has been sent
to the Apollo GraphQL server.
And I have selected
already here,
the mutation that was run to
create the Northstar resort.
You can see the trace
information shows
how long it took to fetch
each individual field
in that mutation.
This is all data that is
produced by Apollo itself,
and is being shipped
off to Google Cloud,
and shown here in
the trace view.
So this gives you a good
view of the individual timing
and tracing information
for specific queries.
What if you want more
trend information,
or over time information
of the data itself?
Apigee collects
analytics information
for every request that
comes through the system.
So let's go over and take
a look at some of that.
Let me switch to
Apigee analytics.
So here, I have created
a custom report in Apigee
that takes a look at the
individual fields that
were fetched for
queries over time,
and also mutations as they
passed through the Apigee
gateway.
This data has been enhanced with
the timing information provided
by Apollo itself.
You can see that it
shows different fields,
how many times each of those
fields have been fetched,
and the average
response time that it
takes to retrieve those fields.
You can also create all types
of reports with this data,
it's not just limited to fields.
You can do different
aggregations, maybe per client,
and which clients are
requesting what kinds of fields.
In fact, let's drill
down into one of these.
So you can see here that the
differing apps, for example,
a product Playground
app, is requesting
some traffic over here
and the peter-app, which
is the one I created, also has
some traffic for the resorts
name.
Hopefully, this
gives you an idea
of how powerful both
combining Apigee analytics
with the cloud tracing
data and cloud logging data
can be to enhance the
information that you
can get for the traffic going
through your GraphQL server.
Well folks, that's
it for the demo.
Now let me hand it
back to you, David,
DAVID FEUER: That
was awesome, Miguel.
Thank you.
So what are three things
you can do today GraphQL?
If you use Apigee
to manage your APIs,
you're one step closer
to your destination.
Go download the GraphQL GitHub
sample and play with it.
We'd love to hear your feedback.
If you're not an Apigee user,
go to apigee.com, try out
the free version of Apigee,
use GraphQL or don't, and do
cool stuff.
We'd love to hear
about that as well.
And lastly, if
you're a GraphQL user
and you want to learn about
the best place to build APIs,
Google Cloud's Cloud Run
is an awesome backend
for your GraphQL
serverless applications.
Definitely check it out.
Thank you so much
for your time today.
We look forward to seeing
you and hearing from you
throughout the week.